il a fallu à peine trois mois pour
tourner la page de près d'un siècle
d'histoire
aujourd'hui le président de la
république et le comité gouvernemental
en charge des questions de politique
étrangère ont conjointement décidé que
la finlande allait demander à devenir
membre de l'otan
c'est un jour historique nouvelle ère
suivent la finlande pays adeptes du
non-alignement militaire s'apprête à
faire son entrée dans l'otan la décision
doit d'abord être voté par le parlement
la suède entend aussi lui emboîter le
pas depuis la chute de l'urss les deux
pays avaient rompu avec la stricte
neutralité en devenant de simples
partenaires de l'otan sans jamais y
adhérer une position qui s'expliquaient
par l'histoire commune avec l'ex union
soviétique
mais l'invasion russe en ukraine a
changé la donne
et l'adhésion de la finlande de la suède
à l'otan renforcerait notre sécurité
commune
démontrerait tu la porte de l'otan est
ouverte et que l'agression ne paie pas
si les états unis disent soutenir ces
candidatures qui doivent obtenir l'aval
de tous les membres de l'alliance la
turquie en revanche se montrent plus
réticentes ankara leur reproche leur
proximité avec le pkk le parti des
travailleurs du kurdistan
considérée comme une organisation
terroriste par la turquie mais aussi
l'union européenne et les etats unis il
devrait y avoir des garanties de
sécurité absolue il ne s'agit pas
seulement de deux pays candidats mais
aussi d'états alliés ils doivent cesser
de soutenir les organisations
terroristes le secrétaire général de
l'otan s'est voulu rassurant un terrain
d'entente pourrait être trouvé avec la
turquie reste la position du kremlin
moscou voit d'un mauvais oeil ce
rapprochement d'autant que la russie
partage 1300 km de frontière avec la
finlande lors d'un dernier échange
téléphonique avec le président
finlandais vladimir poutine a qualifié
d' erreur cette adhésion à l'otan